[Música]
[Aplausos]
durante alguns anos eu já atendi mais de
30 mil pacientes onde a grande maioria
busca por saúde e qualidade de vida eo
tão sonhado emagrecimento tão sonhado
que por muitas vezes tem se tornado um
verdadeiro motivo de compulsão de
obsessão e confesso para vocês que eu
tenho ficado extremamente preocupado
preocupado o que eu tenho visto nos
últimos anos e mais preocupado ainda com
que está por vir
caso nada seja feito eu nunca entendi
tantos jovens com doenças crônicas não
transmissíveis diabetes hipertensão
diversas alterações nos exames de sangue
a pacientes literalmente com sinais e
sintomas de um péssimo estilo de uma
péssima qualidade de vida
além disso a obesidade tem pelo menos
quadruplicado desde 1980 aos dias de
hoje
vejam bem antigamente acontecia
principalmente em países mais
desenvolvidos e hoje também assola
países em desenvolvimento e no brasil
não tem sido diferente de 2006 a 2016
a incidência e prevalência de obesidade
aumentou em 60% hoje 18,9 por cento da
nossa população encontra-se com
obesidade e mais de 50 por cento com
sobrepeso mas o problema é que isso está
acontecendo cada vez mais cedo
a obesidade infantil já é uma realidade
a realidade muito conhecido de nós
profissionais de saúde
estima-se que em 2025 11,3 milhões de
crianças das nossas crianças estejam
obesas 150 mil crianças e jovens com
diabetes 1 milhão de crianças e
pertences e 1,4 milhões de crianças com
gordura no fígado conhecida como
esteatose hepática
a obesidade virou realmente um grande
problema de saúde pública e ela traz
consigo não só aquilo que vocês verem
aquela alteração anatômica cantor
promete cada e até mesmo psicológico e
social da obesidade
ela traz com ela pelo menos 60 tipos de
comorbidades associadas
dentre elas alguns conhecidas como
diabetes hipertensão doenças
cardiovasculares
hoje se sabe que ele traz alguns dos
tesouros de degenerar ativas osteoporose
infertilidade
a apnéia obstrutiva do sono e pelo menos
12 tipos de câncer estão relacionados à
obesidade
isso tem feito isso tem mostrado que em
isso vai representar pelo menos 70%
dessas doenças vão apresentar pelo menos
70% dos olhos da nossa população hoje em
dia 25 milhões de pessoas morrem por
alguma complicação relacionada ao
sobrepeso ou obesidade
sabe que o grande problema disso é que
saúde não é simplesmente a ausência de
doença mas um perfeito bem estar físico
social e de saúde mental
aí eu pergunto a cada um de vocês porque
está acontecendo porque a nossa
população vem se tornando obesa e ainda
mais porque a nossa população vem
adoecendo e prática responder essa
pergunta eu convido a fazer uma viagem
comigo ou viagem comigo ao longo dos
anos
aonde eu vou fazer você entender um
pouco mais todo esse processo que nós
estamos vivendo
vejam só o gênero homo ele está na terra
pelo menos 2,4 milhões de anos e viveu
84 mil gerações através da caça e da
coleta
naquele tempo a alimentação era
completamente infreqüente através de
vegetais frutas
o consumo de proteínas através de
animais de grande porte insetos e o
livro como se fosse hoje eles eram
nômades também eles gastavam muita
energia
já no período neolítico há 10 mil anos
12 mil anos atrás as coisas mudaram um
pouco o homem saiu da caça e da coleta e
começou a domesticar um pouco mais os
animais entender as técnicas
relacionadas à agricultura e aí veio um
pouco da alimentação vegetal para a
nossa mesa como trigo arroz ou até mesmo
milho da américa
além disso vieram ovos leites enfim o
que começou a acontecer é que eles
começaram a produzir isso para
subsistência mas também como forma de
trabalho naquele tempo ele já não era
mais nova disse que já tinha moradia
fixa mas eles gastavam muitas calorias
no próprio trabalho na agricultura e na
pecuária
no século 18 ver a revolução industrial
o grande crescimento grande boom da
população
e com isso a necessidade de produzir
cada vez mais alimentos eo acelerado
essa produção reduziu e muito a
qualidade dos nossos alimentos
alimentação tem ficado cada vez mais
inflamatória o consumo de fibras reduzir
de forma considerável vitaminas e
minerais também reduzir de forma
considerável
nunca se viu tanto açúcar tanto sal e
tanta gordura nos nossos produtos
produtos literalmente industrializados
ultra processados
além do mais trocamos a sopinha da vovó
que vitaminas minerais fitoquímicos
fibras proteínas o produtos embalados
embutidos enlatados
os sucos viraram de caixinha ea sopa
virou soup instantâneo sim muito rápido
dois minutos mas de péssima qualidade
nutricional
além disso o homem moderno ele tem um
lazer e também o trabalho completamente
sedentário
além disso possui é baixa adesão aos
exercícios físicos
é meus amigos o problema ele está
ficando ainda mais grave
sabe o que está acontecendo a gente está
vivendo na era digital e que em tudo em
poucos cliques ou se não for chamado a
siri pode estar palma da sua mão seja
aquele restaurante favorito ele agora
vim pra você ver a sua casa para sua
família através do aplicativo você não
precisa mais se movimentar até o ponto
do táxi
ele também vive até os seus pés pelo
aplicativo veja só as escadas
elas viraram volantes não sabemos mais
até mesmo quando um como vamos ser os
próprios motoristas nossos veículos
as redes sociais têm feito a gente
gastar cada vez menos calorias a média
de cinco a seis horas por dia em redes
sociais aqui no brasil
além disso tem trazido muita ansiedade
para a nossa população e vejam só que
mudança
as crianças hoje em dia tem um a zero
completamente diferente
antigamente a gente ver as crianças
brincando de pega-pega esconde-esconde
ou para quem é do tempo carimba
brincadeiras com bola hoje em dia até
fazer das crianças são como é
completamente sedentário e tem uma coisa
que me avisa muito cara isso é é até
engraçado e cômico
hoje só as relações pessoais elas
mudaram com todas essas redes sociais
opa namorado não precisa mais ir pra o
tempo da tertúlia tertúlia discoteca
balada enfim ela também pode vir através
do aplicativo
o nome dela é df vejam bem senhoras e
senhores
isso tem feito a gente reduzir cada vez
mais o nosso gasto de energia e aumentar
de forma mais considerável ainda o nosso
consumo de calorias a mais não pára por
aí e nós adultos em hoje em dia a gente
sabe que graduação já virou básico né
mas mesmo nela dentro dela se você
quiser se destacar você precisa de um
estágio talvez um motor monitoria ou
talvez até mesmo a iniciação científica
para destacar um pouco mais e você corre
cada vez mais para conquistar isso mas
saiu da graduação há ainda não é o
suficiente se precisa de uma
pós-graduação você precisa de outra
pós-graduação você precisa falar duas
línguas um pa mestrado doutorado e cada
vez você corre mais cara você corre mais
e quando você deve você termina tudo
isso você se depara um belo dia de
domingo quando você está em casa com sua
família você assistir uma palestra do
ted tem uma moça fantástica que ela fala
de habilidade de um profissional do
futuro e disse poxa mas eu não quero
perder tudo que eu ganhei até aqui eu
sei que um que tem que ser só um
profissional do presente eu tenho que
ter essas habilidades do profissional do
futuro liderança criatividade gestão de
pessoas trabalham em equipe gestão
comercial
inteligência emocional olha que
importante isso é um profissional do
futuro e cada vez que ocorre cada vez
que ocorre que tem um monte de boleto
para pagar as contas chegando a família
te cobrando atenção e cada vez que entro
num stress cada vez maior estresse nada
mais é senhoras e senhores do que o teu
corpo percebe um risco em potencial e
esse stress claro vai gerar algumas
alterações no nosso organismo
dentre elas a redução do nosso sistema
imunológico queda do nosso sistema
imunológico aumento da inflamação
e com ela diversas alterações biológicas
também diversas doenças são geradas
através por conta dessa inflamação
aumenta o risco de diabetes estresse
aumenta nossa pressão arterial
além disso causa alteração de diversos
hormônios dentre eles a nossa grande ela
mexe do metabolismo a nossa tireóide que
tem está funcionando super bem quando o
quesito emagrecimento hormônios sexuais
também são influenciados completamente
na situação de stress uma situação de
estresse do animal ele não quer procriar
ele não deve procurar está submetida a
situações de stress e aí uma grande
queda dos níveis de testosterona e uma
grande quantidade de pacientes cada vez
mais jovens no consultório reclamando a
sua sexualidade e do ponto de vista de
composição corporal
o stress aumenta nossa gordura abdominal
reduz a nossa massa muscular e além
disso aumenta também a retenção de
líquidos
só que não para por aí o estresse altera
principalmente a nossa barreira
principal o nosso intestino esse stress
crónico altera o nosso intestino há
permeabilidade do nosso intestino e isso
vai deixar o nosso corpo ainda mais
inflamado e com essa informação ocorre
redução de alguns neurotransmissores
como por exemplo a serotonina do bem
estar e da felicidade ou gaba o
neurotransmissor relacionado a um
neurotransmissor inibitório sistema
nervoso central
também relacionado ao relaxamento é
muito importante para que a gente possa
dormir
além disso isso tem feito a gente ficar
cada vez mais com possível pessoas
estressadas comem mais e como uma
densidade calórica maior necessitando
comer cada vez mais calorias
o stress não pára por aí ele tem uma
relação com outra experiência
comportamental fantástica do ser humano
e que nós estamos perdendo o nosso sono
e o sono tem sido completamente
bombardeado por argumentos que não fazem
o menor sentido
dormir ou perda de tempo trabalho
enquanto eles dormem e viva o que ele
sonho ou a famosa frase do mundo
business the wall street o dinheiro
nunca dorme e com isso e com todo esse
estresse
nós perdemos pelo menos duas horas de
sono desde 1950 até os dias de hoje
hoje mas será que estamos perdendo só o
sono com certeza não o sono ele é muito
importante para o humor da criatividade
para a cognição é durante o sono que
nosso hipocampo se conecta o neocórtex e
faz com que ocorra a consolidação da
memória então está diretamente
relacionado ao aprendizado além disso tá
muito relacionado à resolução de
problemas complexos a mas veja só a era
digital também tem atrapalhado um
pouquinho o nosso sono quer ver uma
coisa fazer uma pergunta pra vocês se
vocês puderem levantar a mão pra mim por
favor quem é que leva o celular pra cama
antes de dormir
nossa eu posso dizer que é 100% que pode
ser que eu não tenho visto alguém que
não levantou
vejam só gente isso dificulta a indução
do sono deixa o nosso sono mais leve a
gente desperta mais vezes durante a
noite aumenta o número de despertares
noturnos em outro dia tá relacionado com
o cansaço e com a fadiga que muitas
vezes não sabe por que está acontecendo
isso acontece principalmente porque
todos nós seres humanos e animais
respondendo respondendo a um ciclo
chamado de ciclo circadiano ciclo do
claro escuro que coordena todas as
nossas reações metabólicas
o que nós estamos fazendo é
interrompendo esse ciclo do claro escuro
quando colocamos a luminosidade de
frente para o nosso trato retina
hipotalâmico que vai se conectar com
outra parte do nosso cérebro que é o
nosso relógio biológico no csio núcleo
supraquiasmático que se conecta com
outros relógio que nós temos no nosso
organismo e além disso causa diversas
alterações
então nós temos alterações agora de
fragmentação do sono alteração do ciclo
circadiano e da redução da quantidade de
horas total do sono
vejam bem isso causa diversas alterações
alterações hormonais como por exemplo o
próprio aumento do hormônio do stress
sim dormir pouco estresse é por isso que
gera alguns sinais e sintomas que eu já
comentar com vocês altera também o nosso
tireóide aumenta a inflamação aumenta o
risco de doenças cardiovasculares
além disso muda completamente o nosso
padrão de alimentação
quem dorme pouco tem mais fome tem menos
a sociedade
além disso é uma necessidade maior de
comer alimentos cada vez mais calórico
mais carboidratos e comer mais doce mais
açúcar mulher sabe do que estou falando
além disso veja bem nós produzimos cada
vez mais grana o hormônio produzido pelo
nosso estômago mas que tem ação do nosso
nuclear que a do nosso cérebro fazendo a
gente aumentar cada vez mais o desejo
por comer e veja só estão relação muito
forte com o aumento do percentual de
gordura e da obesidade que o nosso
cérebro também não gosta desta privação
de sono
a privação do sono por nosso cérebro
aumenta a impulsividade almita
procrastinação aumentar a sensibilidade
emocional ou mulher dpm domingo pouco
sai de perto e veja só a dificuldade de
tomar decisão reduz nosso processo de
aprendizado e memória e além disso
altera a função da nossa milla
responsável principalmente para os
sistemas de recompensa
você quer comer cada vez mais por fome
emocional independente de estar com fome
você quer comer por uma fome emocional e
quantos de nós não tem comido por fome
emocional
vejam só a ciência tem provado quem
dorme menos do que seis horas por dia
aumenta o risco de desenvolvimento de
diabetes doenças cardiovasculares e
coronarianas obesidade está relacionada
à mortalidade
vejam gente no nosso dna ele não foi
feito pra isso por muitos e muitos
milhares de anos
a gente viveu em harmonia com o nosso
meio ambiente
mas hoje com as condições atuais de
civilização estamos vivendo um
verdadeiro ambiente obesogênicos é má
alimentação défice de sono muito stress
cada vez gastando menos energia
vejam isso é um ambiente completamente
obesogênicos e claro sabendo que o
emagrecimento é muito desafiador e como
profissional de saúde como
nutricionistas vou deixar algumas
orientações para cada um de vocês
desliga o celular antes de ir pra cama é
20 ficar com ele
à mesma hora de dormir use as
tecnologias ao seu favor a contar os
passos pra ver o que o gasto de calorias
ou até mesmo para monitorar a quantidade
de horas de sono dormir de noite é
vítima excesso de consumo de bebidas
cafeinadas como café principalmente
depois de cinco horas da tarde
isso pode piorar e muito teu sonho te
deixar mais ansioso e tente estabelecer
um horário fixo para dormir e um horário
fixo para acordar
isso vai melhorar cada vez mais todas as
suas reações metabólicas
evite levar trabalho para casa e se
levar que não seja de forma constante
tem momentos de lazer ou quem sabe até
fazer meditação para controlar todo esse
estresse
faça exercícios físicos 30 a 40 minutos
diariamente
além disso tente se for um adulto dormir
pelo menos sete horas de sono por noite
e quando não puder
assim que puder faça uma reserva de sono
como nutricionista fala pra vocês não se
deixe levar quando você quer emagrecer
por dietas da moda gente a culpa nunca
foi do carboidrato tanta gente chata pra
cortar a tua vida e querendo cortar o
carboidrato
isso não faz o menor sentido
lembre-se frutas e verduras sempre farão
bem ator saúde
ela só precisa estar bem lavadas bebê de
30 a 50 ml o cada quilo de peso corporal
de água diariamente a emagrecer como
menos do que o que se gasta e dois
avisos super importantes
não perca peso rápido demais porque se
você perder peso rápido demais
existe uma grande possibilidade de você
achar até porque as mudanças alimentares
têm que vir com alguns hábitos diários
com mudanças comportamentais
caso não seja assim não vai ser uma
mudança sólida e você vai voltar a
ganhar peso e agora de um ser humano pra
outro
eu desejo a vocês que não fiquem
alinhados à toda essa era industrial e
digital
eu desejo a vocês que vocês voltem a
valorizar sopinha da vovó tão gostosa
nutritiva e reduz o consumo de
industrializados de alimentos ultra
processados em meio a todo esse barulho
valorize o silêncio ele nos apura ele
nos faz crescer
valorize mais as relações pessoais o
olho no olho o aperto de mão aquele
abraço
valorize sim amigos digitais mas também
valoriza os amigos reais e vocês não só
vivam e deixa a vida passar
vivam de forma abundante mas vivam com o
máximo de qualidade de vida que puderem
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]